[Music]
having dealt with the subject of birth I
wish next to explain the educational
system of the Kyrgyz and how it differs
from other systems in the other Greek
states parents who profess to give their
sons the best education place their boys
under the care and control of a moral
tutor as soon as they can understand
what is said to them and send them to a
school to learn letters music in the
exercises of the wrestling ground
moreover they soften the children's feet
by giving them sandals and pamper their
bodies with changes of clothing and it
is customary to allow them as much food
as they can eat the Kyrgyz on the
contrary instead of leaving each father
to a point a slave to act as tutor gave
the duty of controlling the boys to a
member of the class from which the
highest offices are filled in fact to
the warden as he was called he gave this
personal authority to gather the boys
together to take charge of them and to
punish them severely
in case of misconduct he also assigned
him a staff of youths provided with
whips to chastise them when necessary
and the result is that modesty and
obedience are inseparable companions at
Sparta instead of softening the boys
feet with sandals he required them to
harden their feet by going without shoes
he believed that if this habit were
cultivated it would enable them to climb
Hills more easily and discerned steep
inclines with less danger and that a
youth who had accustomed himself to go
barefoot with leap and jump and run all
nimbly than a boy in sandals and instead
of letting them be pampered in the
matter of clothing he introduced the
custom of wearing one garment throughout
the year believing that they would thus
be better prepared to face changes of
heat and cold as to the food he required
the prefect to bring with him such a
moderate amount
it that the boys would never suffer from
repletion and would know what it was to
go with their hunger unsatisfied free
believed that those who underwent this
training would be better able to
continue working on an empty stomach
if necessary and will be capable of
going on longer without extra food if
the word of command were given to do so
they would want fewer delicacies and
will accommodate themselves more readily
to anything put before them and at the
same time would enjoy better health he
also thought that a diet which made
their bodies slim would do more to
increase their height than one that
consisted of flesh forming food on the
other hand unless that they should feel
too much the pinch of hunger while not
giving them the opportunity of taking
what they wanted without trouble he
allowed them to alleviate their hunger
by stealing something it was not on
account of a difficulty in providing for
them that he encouraged them to get
their food by their own cunning no one I
suppose could fail to see that obviously
a man who intends to take up thieving
must spend sleepless nights and play the
deceiver and lie in ambush by day and
moreover if he means to make a capture
then he must have spies ready there can
be no doubt then that all this education
was planned by him in order to make the
boys more resourceful in getting
supplies and better fighting men someone
may ask but why if he believed stealing
to be a fine thing did he have the boy
who was caught beaten with many stripes
I reply because in all cases men punish
a learner for not carrying out properly
what he is taught to do so the Spartans
chastised those who get caught for
stealing badly
he made it a point of honor to steal as
many cheeses as possible from the altar
of artemis or thea but appointed others
to scourge the thieves meaning to show
their by that by enduring pain for a
short time one may win the lasting fame
and felicity it is shown here in that
where there is need of swiftness the
slothful as usual gets a little profit
and many troubles in order that the boys
might never lack a ruler even when the
warden was away he gave authority to any
citizen who chanced to be present to
require them to do anything that he
thought right and to punish them for any
misconduct this had the effect of making
the boys more respectful in fact boys
and men alike respect their rulers above
everything and that a rule that might
not be lacking to the boys even when no
grown man happened to be present he
selected the keenest of the prefect s'
and gave to each the command of a
division and so at Sparta the boys are
never without parola I think I ought to
say something about intimacy with the
boys
since this matter also has a bearing on
education for instance among the
Boeotians man and boy lived together
like married people elsewhere among
their lands for example consent is won
by means of favors some on the other
hand entirely forbid suitors to talk
with boys the customs instituted by the
Kyrgyz were opposed to all of these if
someone being himself an honest man
admired a boys soul and tried to make
him an ideal friend without reproach and
to associate with him he approved and
believed in the excellence of this kind
of training but if it was clear that the
attraction lay and the boys outward
beauty he banned the connection as an
abomination and thus he calls lovers to
abstain from boys no less than parents
abstain from sexual intercourse with
their children and brothers and sisters
with each other
I am not surprised however that people
refuse to believe this for in many
states the laws are not opposed to the
indulgence of these appetites I have now
dealt with a Spartan system of Education
and that of the other Greek States which
system turns out men more obedient more
respectful and more strictly temperate
or anyone who chooses a once more judge
for himself
you